I'm I'm I'm protective because it's like
not only are they not like full grown
women yet but also you're a s I am a
hella I am a [__]
s believe all wom I can't I just got to
be Captain sa
[Music]
ho storm are you guys ready for some JK
Justice I love it
right so I'm going to give you a
scenario that actually happened in real
life and you guys tell me what the JK
Justice should be okay so a woman is in
a
Chipotle and she is angry at a Chipotle
employee um and she decided to take her
bowl of Chipotle and then Chuck it at
the Chipotle employee that's not nice is
it because she was short on the avocado
and she was like put some more avocado
in there I ordered extra it could very
well be they didn't really say they just
said that she was she had a um an
altercation and then she was mad because
um she had been working at
Chipotle um or she hadn't been working
at Chipotle she had been visiting the
Chipotle she didn't get her breedable
the way that she liked it and then um
the woman at CH who worked for Chipotle
was like and oh this is how you respond
to it you're going to Chuck a b Chipotle
at me and then um that's when the the
system of Justice took over so what do
you think they did did the workers hop
over and start [__] up the salad
tosser think more like J JK Justice what
would they make her do JK Justice wait
wait who who's being justified the lady
who threw the burrito the woman who
threw the burrito so he's asking us to
Guess what at the employee she threw it
at the Chipotle employee what do you
think oh I think she got all the
ingredients dumped back onto her that's
that's she got wrapped in a burrito I I
would that's W fu yeah ey for an eye
lettuce for a lettuce that's slapstick
Justice that's a little Wong fuy a
little long they threw in a trash can
they threw in the trash can close but no
ose they threw her out of the store oh
did they do that thing from movies where
you where you drag someone across the
bar but it was really the flat grill bar
it was a flat grill even I want to say
yes so bad all the Tobasco bottles no
they senten her to work at fast food for
2 months Chipotle sick at Chipotle the
judge did Judge did yeah now you know
how hard it is and stop complaining but
then is that with no wages like she has
to like it's like it's like her
community
service that's sick there's no way that
is her community service so I think I
think you're I think I think they should
do that in a [__] really rich
neighborhood where they have like all
these [__] things they want perfectly
done for their order oh yeah yeah yeah
Beverly Hills trip if when she's on her
shift you don't have to throw your bowl
in the trash you got to just toss it at
her and she just has to pick it up she
is the trash can so she has to climb
into one of these right yeah and then
that's where you put Filipino food yeah
and then when you step on her toe her
mouth opens up and you have to throw the
trash in her yeah you got to hit bricks
all
day I wish they did that for all the
laws any anything you break you have to
do the receiving end of it so you learn
empathy not to do what kind of beautiful
place would allow this as a punishment
uh that is an excellent question Joe
America go so one of the the employee
who was attacked said this [__] is
lucky basically cuz I had to work like
[__] 65 hours a week and she only has
to work 20 hours a week for fast food
but still that's pretty tight the judge
did yeah I like that and I love it how
it's a punishment and all the workers
are like wait what the [__] our job is a
punishment stit you to what they do yeah
dang I didn't look at it that way yeah
and they didn't say she has to work at
Chipotle by the way they just said she
has to work at a fast food cake oh why
she goes to Shake Shack and it's like
that's not fair yeah or two upscale or
what's the one five guys is that why is
JK Justice cuz the punishment doesn't
actually make sense I think real JK
Justice is if she climbed over the
counter and started [__] her
up that's JK Justice you know um that's
some that's one of my favorite things to
watch is like when people fight at uh
McDonald's and then they try to hop over
the counter and then the workers start
like [__] jumping up I love when the
workers fight back the only thing I
don't like about that is you the workers
almost always end up fired which sucks
see I don't like think about that but
you know what I would like to do one day
is invite them all to work at June be
that's cool I would just be like move
the fight to Jun would you would you
fire them okay if somebody at Jun be
gone to fight with a customer that was
wrong I would always protect my
employees even if the public is like hey
June P let this violent thing happen J
is fight friendly dude oh yeah you fight
in a J We're powered by matcha dude we
[__] drink that bombass guava matcha
and we're just like all right I got
McGregor in me now let's go green just
like the Irish did you did you did you
have anything close to that happen like
a disgruntled customer come back and be
pretty pissed off yeah I I was actually
pretty well not a this he was kind of
crazy but I was actually very proud of
my two employees they're like you know I
think one was in high school at the time
and then the other one she's like 21 22
so they're fairly young and it was this
guy that was like hella aggressive
toward them I wasn't there that day
and um I don't know what type of grown
man would tell like a little girl to be
like step outside that's [__] what
see like that's [__] up in theory when
you hear his second hand is really funny
it is ridiculous right so I it's was
like okay nice to see equality I love
equality we saw the camera footage this
guy looks like at least mid-40s he's
like come outside come on let's go what
the [__] I know my team they're [__]
sweet like there's no there's never a
time when it should happen so it's un
this is what I guess our just from
hearing the story right like our
assessment of this whole thing is it
sounds like a guy that felt ignored by a
girl and he feels like all crazy because
it's like you're not you're not giving
me my [__] respect that I deserve
like it's not even about the customer
service it's about like yeah he wasn't
even ordering anything he was asking for
directions or some [__] [__] he's
not even a customer oh that's that's St
and so it it turned into this
altercation and [__] telling the girls
like step outside and see what I do
right she steps outside I would not
recommend this she she goes what are you
going to do then this she's a skinny 22y
old girl [__] you didn't say she was
micronesian though that's dope she was
like what are you going to do then right
and then he just walked away I was
like don't ever do that I told her don't
ever do that but damn you're [__]
tough tight and I'm like damn you were
wearing your hoop earrings that day huh
you had to go like [__] what's up
scrap you want a scrap did you give her
raise yeah she's get she's getting a
raise not for that but for other reasons
because she's just a worker she's like
every opponent you
defeat that's a dollar we count that as
a win cuz he forfeited so yeah yeah yeah
you're one and0 baby if I go to jby and
I don't order anything can I use the
bathroom of course that's sick dude you
know what we have [__] napkins straws
people just [__] walk up and grab
[__] without saying thank you they just
walk away dude take it f you lucky your
your uh place is not here cuz we would
do so many pranks oh my God there is a
place here it's just not ran under me
but please prank the one the one where
it's you I would I would do so much I
would just be a [__] character be
like why is my drink all
green that's so good that's great dang
no I think I think for me it's just dude
there was another time too where um a a
food delivery guy well he was bringing
ingredients and supplies right and this
[__] always happens when there's never a
guy around like we have a storage area
with refrigerators and [__] right and
then there's no cameras in this hallway
so again middle-aged dude [__] weird
and then there was a you know I think
she another girl that was 17 or 18 but
she's a little too young to be [__]
probably isolated with this dude right
so she needed to show him where to put
all the [__] milks and all that stuff
so as he's doing that he's sexually
harassing her no touching right just all
like aggressive verbal [__] what the
[__] so I [__] chewed out the
dispatch on the phone I said hey look if
you even accidentally bring this guy to
the shop because he's scheduled if we
ever see him ever again we're never
going to buy anything from you guys and
on top of that it's a liability to you I
have underage workers imagine if he did
something [__] up and we got you know
camera footage of him saying
inappropriate things um initially at the
store and then they're like oh oh we are
so sorry he's been reprimanded I was
like man I will [__] reprimand his
face yeah and that's when we need 30%
off all the sugar and the
cream but there there's things like that
that go on right and I'm just like I'm
I'm I'm protective because it's like not
only are they not like full grown women
yet but also you're a s I am a hella I
am a [__]
s believe all women I can't I just got
to be Captain
sa he comes in like that'll never happen
to you
[Applause]
again not when not when Daddy Joe is
around daddy Joe got you always girl
daddy Jo you come daddy Jo first
nobody's going to [__] with you again
come here baby you got something on your
face
yeah